the fact that something with this
unintentional attention to detail is
technically a bug in Red Dead Redemption
2 blows my mind this was posted on the
Red Dead Redemption 2 subreddit a while
ago but I only just found it basically
if you walk into this room as Arthur
Morgan dinamite this woman out the
window and then it triggers the cut
scene which is what that weird jump just
was she comes back through very bloody
and then on fire and then throughout the
duration of this conversation
effectively burns alive she even loses
her arm now she's covered in Burn good
to see you Mary obviously they did not
factor in the character actually dying
here because it shouldn't technically be
possible but the fact that she's still
steaming as she walks out of the
room this is genuinely probably the best
cut scene glitch I have ever seen in my
life